bonsoir 36 km uh merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes président de l'union des
maires de l'essonne maire radicaux
centristes dini vous êtes avec nous vous
souhaitez vous donc l'ouverture de
centres de vaccination dans votre
commune indispensable selon vous
aujourd'hui pour tenter d'accélérer
cette cadence
oui au delà de notre commune ce que l'on
ressent aujourd'hui c'est un double
cafouillage la part des administrations
en général c'est d'abord un cafouillage
dans l'axé prioritaire aux soins on a
bien vu aujourd'hui l'accélération du
temps je sers présent la stratégie de
l'état depuis décembre qui viennent
arrêter était de vacciner en éviter le
pilier personnel et les personnes dans
les ehpad
aujourd'hui olivier viron le ministre de
la santé a élargi les priorités sous
l'effet de la semaine alarme qui a été
tirée par les maires et à sa commande de
deux professionnels en élargissant les
priorités aux personnes de plus de 75
ans en dehors des épaves
ça veut dire que sont déjà plusieurs
millions de personnes qui sont
potentiellement concernés par le vaccin
de manière prioritaire et aujourd'hui on
fait ce que l'on ressent de plus en plus
c'est une forme de crainte de l'état de
revivre à l'envers le fiasco de la crise
vaccinale achat il ya dix ans il ya dix
ans et bien la seconde de sang qui
étaient ouverts sur les territoires en
essonne nous avions 17 centres qui
étaient ouverts qui était adossé au sial
juive au centre hospitalier et on s'est
aperçu finalement quand vous regardez
dossier à l'époque
finalement à autant de gens prévus sont
allés dans les centres de vaccination
pour une maladie qui s'est réveillée
plus bénite en tout cas par rapport aux
communes 19 et aujourd'hui le spectre
qu'ils vont nous c'est de revivre
linverse l' inverse c'est à dire ne pas
avoir suffisamment de centres de
vaccination sur l'ensemble des
territoires oliveira annonce environ si
son centre pour la fin du mois de
janvier sur l'ensemble de la france
ça veut dire en rien ou six centres par
département alors même que l'on rêve de
voir accélérer la vaccination au
printemps et aujourd'hui ce que l'on dit
nous les élus les maires et les belles
et les départements on n'est pas prêt
donc on demande simplement n'ont pas
forcément de reprendre la main
misia l'instant dans vos titres mais
simplement on souhaite participer à la
campagne de vaccination parce que nous
sommes tous dans le même bateau
on va tous travailler pour sortir par le
haut de la crise
comment justement est accueilli par le
gouvernement votre démarche à ce que
vous avez eu l'occasion vous les maires
en tout cas d'avoir un retour justement
de cette proposition des dents si on a
bien compris aux autorités alors on a
les prières en essonne on a fait une
lettre cosignée avec le président du
département et moi même en tant que
représentant des maires de l'essonne à
emmanuel macron la lettre les parties et
guerre nous sommes en relation régulière
avec en essonne le préfet de l'essonne
avec lequel nous avons des relations
tout à fait constructive mais
aujourd'hui les réponses au plus tôt
poli la réponse aujourd'hui du préfet de
l'essonne c'est de dire ça avance on
s'organise on entend vos propositions et
aujourd'hui s'arrête là simplement
lorsque l'on veut mettre en place des
centres de vaccination et ça prend du
temps ça prend plusieurs semaines
certains maires sont prêts en réaliser
des centres je dirais un but et moi
comme à kouassi avec mon collègue karl
olive
mais ça s'organise ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui si on veut être prêt en
avril mais projet ciné de l'argent la
population c'est maintenant qu'on peut
aussi prendre c'est maintenant pour
organiser une carte spatiale de ses
futurs centres et ne pas attendre
d'abord la campagne prioritaire de
validation de qu'elle se met en place et
on s'accélère depuis quelques heures
clairement pour bien qu'on comprenne
aujourd'hui comment ça se passe
concrètement dans votre commune olivier
verrons a dit accélérer la cadence
comment ça se passe où sont par exemple
les doses de vaccin
avant d'être acheminés dans l'est dans
les hôpitaux alors aujourd'hui en fait
on a eu la course cet après-midi en
interne d'avoir par exemple sur le
département de l'essonne
trois centres de vaccination où seront
stockés ont proposé les les vaccins de
son troisième but à longjumeau evry et
étampes dans le sud de l'essonne
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui on sait
qu'on a un sujet logistique de
conservation du vaccin avec l'esprit de
l'eau une solution adaptée mais encore
une fois on n'a qu'une partie des
informations
est ce que l'on ressent finalement si
une forme de péché d'orgueil de
l'administration et de l'état qui
consiste à tracer sa route dans ses
stratégies vaccinales d'entendre
poliment les propositions et des
collectivités nous on sait au bon c'est
mettre en mettre en place des lieux on
l'a montré il ya dix ans les
collectivités d'en montrer avec toute
une chaîne logistique
en revanche on sait que l'état son rôle
c'est de cette c'est de vacciner est ce
que l'on regrette simplement c'est de ne
pas être dans une relation totalement
transparents on ne voit pas ce que
craint l'état et l'administration de
travailler main dans la main des
territoires fant c'est ce qu'avait à
vigo roma prochaine question se souvient
de jean castex fraîchement élu qui nous
parlait de décentralisation avec son
accent chantant du sud comment vous
expliquer cette forme je ne sais pas si
on peut parler de défiance mais voilà de
ne pas finalement faire confiance aux
régions au maire de ne pas déléguer
alors que manifestations on vend il
faudrait le faire et je vais vous dire
je pense que tout simplement on a on a
un système qui est grippé
moi je le vois je suis maire depuis six
ans on a à faire dans nos partenaires
publics régulièrement de grands
professionnels de l'action publique
parmi les fonctionnaires des différents
types de professionnels
mais je crois que c'est le système qui
est grippé je pense que malheureusement
aujourd'hui on sent que healy à cet
autre cette tentation qui est parce que
culturelle en france avoir une
bureaucratie forte très descendante très
très verticale aujourd'hui c'est ce
qu'on dénonce
à rebours de l'histoire quand on regarde
toutes nos les démocraties nos voisins
aujourd'hui le système est totalement
territorialisées et si on avait un état
efficace et fort dans ses compétences
régaliennes et des territoires qui le
sont tout autant dans la compétence ça
fonctionnerait bienvenus le problème je
pense qu'il est vraiment structurelles
on a affaire à des personnes qui ce
qu'ils veulent bien faire mais on a ce
problème de confiance tout simplement
entre les territoires et
l'administration
donc on doit définitivement
décentraliser ce pays ne pas le faire
d'une manière en catimini ou à marche
forcée à reculons après il faut
réellement le faire
vous savez moi je suis persuadé que
cette fille sanitaire ça veut dire que
c'est le début du 21e siècle dans nos
livres d'histoire parce qu'on a été au
collège en vicier on disait que le xxème
siècle a démarré après la guerre de
14-18 bien moi je pense que le 21e
siècle démarre avec cette crise
sanitaire
eh bien on doit le démarrer en france
avec une vraie décentralisation
merci beaucoup en tout cas à prendre ce
qui est rigolo président de l'union des
maires de l'essonne d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france